no pressure though welcome to the
workshop recap
kinetic fire 2012.
and by that i mean 2014.
this is eli herrod and he's going to
recap his workshop on
three poi stack swapping
so for me it all starts right here
yeah yeah sorry
let's go right here
awesome stuff
all right so then there's all the
superman stuff
can you break that down briefly just uh
real quick
so starting here
yep bounce around everything comes
in hand switches bounce around
switch hands
pull around close pull back out with the
other hand
always switching the pink on that one
then there's the same thing with fan
four
and four down close
switch the thumb into pinky grip of the
other hand
and forward down just like so
always going down
coming up switching which
which is
there was the kryptonite the swap
okay so kryptonite
bouncing on the native side and going
around native
so it's bounce bounce
close then that one bounce
bounce close balance
then there was a mixing in an over the
head trace with that
so you bounce around and then
as the other one goes around you
there it is
something like that so
knee trace
that guy with the superman
bouncing forward hitting the ankle
slow-mo
just like that then you
out of that use the superman stack swap
to switch to doing it with the other
side
and you can do a head trace
against that
like so
and then there was using using the
armpit pinch as an entrance to the
cascade
going from a standard tubie weave
pinching the pinky in the armpit and
then using that to
toss out into juggling
and you can attach into a weave and go
right back into the stack swap nonsense
what was the one you found this morning
there was one you found this morning
right
that was tonight okay and then there was
the
other knee trace where he went from the
outside
so
starting from here thumb sides on the
shoulder
pinky side swinging back and forth so
you got this pass
just passing the pinky back and forth oh
that's the second time that's happened
so what you do is right as you make that
pass
you lift your knee to hit the inside of
your leg
make the pass loop around
and repeat as you come down to hit the
knee
pass around move pass
i think that was it sweet uh can you do
that two-point cap
with the nobitos oh yeah yeah
yeah really simple
oh and then there was oh yeah there was
some more cool stuff there was this one
from here
that guy then there was this one
from here going behind the back catching
like that
that's a tough one
three poi stack swap 1997. wait one more
thing
with the fan four stack swap i forgot
about the leg cross
so how it was a knee knee
like that instead you can do
inside one knee for the first one and
outside of the other knee for the second
one
so it's knee
that's it
thank you eli eli harrod
1998 kinetic fire
winter 1998 woo